bonsoir je suis sur l'un des sites les
plus célèbres au monde la baie du mont
saint michel offre certainement le plus
beau panorama de ces jeux équestres et
accueille surtout l'épreuve la plus
longue
l'endurance 160 kilomètres à parcourir
le plus vite possible depuis 7h ce matin
et jusqu'à 20h30 au plus tard un
véritable marathon pratiqué par le même
cavalier et le même cheval
résumé du jour chrono en m'a préparé par
franck besnier c'est le jour le plus
long sur ces jeux sartilly ce petit
village de la baie du mont saint michel
est en ébullition 7h ce matin 166
cavaliers de 45 nations s'élance dans
cette épreuve d'endurance
au programme cinq boucles à parcourir
dans des paysages à couper le souffle
les grands favoris les voici les
cavaliers des émirats arabes unis le
prix de leurs chevaux dépassent souvent
le million d'euros après quelques
minutes de course
l'info tombe un cheval du costa rica est
décédé après avoir percuté un arbre sa
cavalière légèrement blessé a été
transporté à l'hôpital dans cette course
éprouvante des contrôles vétérinaires
ont lieu tout au long du parcours
c'est une donne avec laquelle il faut
jouer qui est la subjectivité des juges
vétérinaire faut jouer avec des fois ça
passe des fois ça passe par à une
moyenne de 20 km heure pour les
meilleurs les premiers cavaliers des
émirats vont mettre 11 heures pour
boucler les 160 km de cette épreuve
d'endurance
les premiers français était pointé en
fin d'après-midi à la 30e place dans le
prestigieux cadre du haras du pin coup
d'envoi ce matin du concours complet une
épreuve qui allie le saut d'obstacles le
cross et le dressage en piste pascal
leroy un cavalier de 56 ans installé en
loire atlantique
il a déjà participé à cinq coupes du
monde la pression il connaît et son
cheval minos de petra va se crisper
on est en france il y avait peut-être un
peu plus de supporters français qui ont
applaudi avant la prestation et j'ai
senti que je sois se contracter un petit
peu à ce moment là donc la transmission
et la connexion avec le cheval est un
peu moins bonne et j'ai pas pu demander
les choses comme je les demande est
habituellement le show des cowboys a
repris cet après midi à caen avec les
épreuves de reining en selle les
français anne sophie et cédric guerrero
oui les américains étaient trop forts
pour eux enfin on part adressage la
beauvaisis à nathalie bizet a manqué son
passage elle retourne de la sixième à la
dixième place après quatre jours
d'épreuves
on attend toujours la première médaille
française
je suis maintenant sur la zone de repos
c'est l'endroit où les chevaux récupère
avant de repartir sur le parcours et je
suis avec thierry qui est propriétaire
d'un cheval
comment ça se passe le contrôle ils sont
contrôlés tous les combien comme
encaisse les contrôles après chaque
boucle en fait on regarde s'ils ont le
bon rythme cardiaque il faut qu'il soit
inférieur à 64 pour être validés et en
plus après on fait un contrôle les
allures pour savoir si à 6 h aux halles
qui boite donc s'il doit-il éliminer les
pas autorisé à repartir sur la boucle
suivante non pas de problème pour les
français pour l'instant aucun problème
pour le storeway vous n'avez pas l'air
stressé du tout du tout du tout non
moins bon courage
on est sûr qu'on est sûre de l'équipe on
est sur des choses il ya pas de problème
du courage il en faut aussi pour être
cavaliers de parra dressage la seule
compétition mixte des jeux équestres
disciplines officielles depuis 2010 lors
des jeux de lexington cette version
handisport du dressage peine à
s'installer et souffre du désintérêt du
public
chamakh at elle participe à ses premiers
jeux pour lui c'est l'occasion de faire
découvrir sa passion même si le public
se fait un peu désirer
on regrette un peu parc à l'hippodrome
alors que les dresseurs ils sont au
stade d'ornano
après bon c'est un peu le bazar dans la
billetterie et où je pense qu'il ya eu
quelques problèmes de gestion par
rapport à ça les tribunaux sont pas sont
pas comblés après on est super contents
d'être d'être ici et de et de faire
parce qu'on sait faire puisque les gens
connaissent pas trop pas trop ce que
c'est c'est vrai les tribunes se
remplissent doucement en fonction du
temps et entre deux rayons de soleil on
découvre un public éclectique composé de
passionnés venus de loin mais aussi des
voisins curieux qui expérimentent les
jeux c'est très intéressant se
connaissaient pas du tout et
on découvrait et vraiment on prend
plaisir ils sont un très haut niveau de
jeu et avec un handicap surmonté leurs
rancoeurs
c'est pour moi c'est formidable je suis
très admiratif
moi aussi je suis un câblier des parades
à sage et nous voulons voir les niveaux
établis internationaux et nous avons vu
que l'ennemi procès après des sauts et
vous pouvez encore en profiter jusqu'à
vendredi
il reste quelques places vendues 5 euros
alors un petit conseil venez impôts
drôme
une heure avant le début des épreuves et
ainsi vous pourrez peut-être imiter le
support aux australiens du public
il y en à l'organisation de ce marathon
équestre demande une rigueur sans faille
et des petites mains en pagaille qu'il a
fallu recruter au plus près c'est comme
ça qu'un jeune normand espoir de la boxe
a laissé tomber les gants pour
l'occasion depuis deux ans il boxe dans
la cour des grands à 23 ans maxime
beaussire a déjà fait 16 combats en
professionnel le saint-lois lisent
aujourd'hui le titre de champion de
france
d'habitude dans la lumière le voici
aujourd'hui qui fait partie des petites
mains des jeux équestres mondiaux vient
du milieu de la terre donc tout ça sans
en donner
je connais par coeur tout ça et puis
voilà faut savoir rester les pieds sur
terre de toute façon pendant ces deux
jours il assure l'assistance pour le
cheval dont il a la charge
un milieu qu'il connaît bien en fait et
depuis longtemps j'ai pratiqué cinq ans
connaît club à saint lô quand j'étais
gamin
puis après il s'est trouvé que ça a été
très bénéfique puisque ma copine et
cavalières pro donc on a même un cheval
en commun et je continue à monter à
cheval a assez régulièrement
régulièrement entre deux entraînements
de boxe maxime beaussire devient groom
pour une équipe de haut niveau
d'endurance cette fois ci il a été
embauché par hong kong
le cheval c'est comme le boxeur comme
les sportifs anglais en général c'est un
véritable athlète et j'admire ces
animaux là il n'oublie pas qu'en octobre
il a son propre combat sur le parcours
d'endurance la compétition touche à sa
fin dans à peine plus d'une heure
l'épreuve sera officiellement terminé
pour les 170 cavaliers et leurs chevaux
que ce soit pour le meilleur ou pour le
pire ils ont tous gagné un privilège
celui de concourir sur un site
d'exception